so thank you both for agreeing to speak
with us today about the future retail I
think it's an exciting topic because
it's no secret that everyone loves to
shop shopping brings us discovery drama
gamification even transformation at
times so to start off I know that rent
the runway launched its mobile
application in 2013 and since still
brings in near forty percent of its web
traffic from mobile guilt and other big
retailers use a mobile first strategy
and Scarlett you've been on the board of
a lot of these companies that do use a
mobile first strategy so in today's
world how important is mobile to retail
so first of all can you hear me
I'll just switch to this can hear me now
so first of all thank you so much for
having me here today I must say that
when I graduated Yale I did absolutely
nothing in tech while I was there and
it's so nice to see so many people here
today focused around that topic so great
to see thanks for having me I also say
it's a little tough to follow Henry who
not only has lots of stories but is also
a great storyteller so I don't know that
we can match the the energy level that
he had we'll do our best and so moving
on to mobile you know emarketer last
year had estimated for this year that
the you all the US online retail market
would be somewhere on three hundred
billion dollars and of that the estimate
was at nineteen percent would be mobile
and you know I was just looking at some
data yesterday around what is being seen
today you know pretty o an online
advertising company that we know well
and does a lot of work with global
e-commerce companies today is saying and
in their most left most recent report
that thirty percent of that online
retail market is now coming from mobile
so clearly the market is growing it's
growing very fast you know the growth
rate for mobile commerce is thirty
percent as opposed to online retail in
general which is more in the sort of
twelve to fifteen percent range so you
know clearly an interesting area
obviously everyone here is carrying a
phone today you know the the penetration
of smartphones throughout the world has
really lent itself to mobile being such
a great way for people to access
information access purchasing on their
device so it's not so much you know as
we look at his investors you know the
question is no longer do you have a
mobile strategy but what in fact is the
mobile strategy so you know it's very
rare now you know and I tend to focus on
growth as Ali mentioned if you if you
look at you know some of the companies
are coming in even at the early stage
side the difference is really how is
that mobile experience so I think where
there's still work to be done and still
really interesting opportunity is making
that experience as user friendly as
possible i still feel there's a lot of
friction in terms of the process of
purchasing you know the the
are not totally optimized necessarily
for mobile devices you know you want to
have an experience where the user can
very quickly see what's happening very
quickly get to a point where they can
make a purchase and that's where I feel
that there's still some friction so
there's been a lot of improvement more
to be done and of course that's
reflected in some of the conversion
rates you see where they're still lower
on mobile devices relative to what you
see on the desktop I'll try my own is
just a few observations on mobile that
we've seen one is to me when I hear
mobile first I actually think of that in
terms of our development strategy so we
started to develop on mobile devices
prior to developing online on the web
and I love that I'm obsessed with the
fact that we can now work more quickly
we can be forced to simplify things
which is really so important in the
world of e-commerce another thing I'd
say that is that in the world of retail
especially as you start to go offline
which Rent the Runway has recently done
with some brick and mortar stores
there's amazing ways in which mobile can
blur the lines between ecommerce and
physical brick-and-mortar stores because
all of a sudden you have a device in
each consumers hand that could enable
you to find out so much information and
details about who that consumer actually
is when in the past and when walking
into a physical store you don't really
know who they are right so you're not
armed with the same personalization
abilities as you are typically in
e-commerce so I think those two things
alone have so many more so many
opportunities for mobile to play a
bigger and bigger role as companies of
all so as you brought up a lot of
companies today are making that switch
from online to offline I know that Rent
the Runway has done this quite
successfully and is now in New York in
Las Vegas we had nasty gal all over the
news for their opening of their first
brick-and-mortar store as well I'd love
to hear some of your views on the pros
and cons of going from an e-commerce
online platform to a physical location I
start short or um so also great to be
here and wonderful to see all of you in
the audience and so engaged I am so
thrilled that Yale has become such a
supporter of entrepreneurship
technology and there's so many amazing
things that they're doing in the space
right now and Rent the Runway for me has
been a dream amazing company to build
who here has heard of rent the runway
yay and who is tried rent the runway
okay given that like eighty percent of
your men I'm going to get a good
percentage but so we rented einer
dresses and accessories and we've been
around for about six years now and most
recently we've introduced a retail
strategy starting a couple of years ago
and that stemmed from our customers
constantly asking us can we try on your
dresses can we see them in person can
you feel them in person and many people
who were not yet our customers telling
us that that was kind of their friction
point they were like and you know like
rentals new concept but if I could like
try it on I would know that it fit in it
would just give me that confidence to
talk to someone in person ask them all
my questions that I need to get over the
hump and try rental so we heard it
enough that we said you know what we've
got the e-commerce thing grooving we're
going to keep our Don that that's going
to be the core of what we are as a
company but let's start experimenting
with retail and whenever we evolve our
strategy as a start-up we are constantly
doing what i call minimum viable product
testing where we're inching our way
we're crawling rather than walking or
running into the new strategy so with
retail that meant throwing up a store
inside our office where we could just
watch what was happening we spent in a
less than ten thousand dollars we
started inviting customers in a very
quiet way to come try on our dresses and
we're like let's see what this does to
conversion let's see what the average
order prices is this going to be
profitable as it standalone profitable
how does it interact with the website
and the results were off the chart
conversion was over seventy percent
which you know online conversion numbers
are typically and more in the three to
ten percent range average order values
or twice what they were and I would say
most importantly it was letting us see
our customers really interact with the
product in a way that just draws new
insights every single day so when you
can watch a customer physically interact
and hear what they're saying to their
friends or whoever they're bringing with
them in a shopping experience or to our
stylists you start to learn so many
things that you can actually apply
online the other thing it did is it got
us thinking about what could the
interplay be between physical retail
stores and online e-commerce
and that's actually a lot of how our
retail strategy has evolved to date so
now we have two stores in New York and
we have one in DC and we're opening one
next week in Chicago so if anyone's from
that area it's going to be gorgeous and
we'll be out there kind of launching and
opening the store and and what we've
started to do is we've used our retail
stores to enhance our online experience
so you can do things now like you can
pick up your order in store which many
companies have that that may not seem
revolutionary but for a company like
rent the runway that is very event
focused it means that a woman can come
in on a Friday she can try her address
on which is very rapidly you know
revolutionary for us if it doesn't fit
there's thousands of other dresses in
the store she can swap it she can talk
to a stylist she can accessorize her
outfit which means you know extra
revenue for us but for her it actually
lets her play and try on a bunch of
different things we've experimented with
hemming services so if the dress needs a
little bit of a hem you know she brings
her high heels and she can get it hemmed
for her special night out with a
temporary hem so for our business in
particular because that event was often
the next day and that occasions were
such high stakes occasions at someone's
wedding etc women you know really wanted
a way to get the experience to be
perfect so so that's you know way in
which I'd say our strategies a little
bit unique we've also seen a huge halo
of marketing benefits from our store so
we actively track you know in the New
York area in the Chicago area once we
launched a physical retail store what
does it do to the lift online for our
online business and of course you'd
attract cannibalization as well but for
our online business we see a large boost
in halo effect and we actually attribute
our retail stores it's a marketing
expense in a way so in that in that
venue alone it's been hugely effective
our goal is to make our retail stores
standalone profitable in year one we are
close and we believe we can do it which
is great but I think to speak to some of
the cons because I've talked about a lot
of the pros of retail there's some of
the cons initially or it's not as but
you can't scale as quickly so it's
amazing to see both to rent the runway
and so many startups what ecommerce has
done in terms of letting us scale and
grow very quickly we have 5 million
members to rent the runway to do that in
a retail capacity would be far more
challenging we felt a real brand that
has significance throughout the u.s.
throughout the world to some extent to
our consumers to do that with retail
just takes more time so I love that
we've been able to doubt ecommerce and
then retail can be expensive and you're
often locking yourself in to multi-year
leases so again whenever we can get a
two-year sublease or five-year lease we
do it but often to get the best spaces
you need a 10-year lease which is a huge
huge kind of financial commitment that
you're making if you're doing it
especially as your first step as a
business that's a big risk maybe you're
doing it without all the information
you'd ideally have and that you'd be
able to garner online and that would i'd
say be my final point is that i think
when you think of pros cons i go back
again to the comment I made about the
information you're armed with as an
online business versus a physical
brick-and-mortar business and I do think
you know someone comes to your site and
you know what their past browsing
behavior is you often know what other
websites they offend to you know where
that what region they live in you know
what their searches have been before
what size they are you know maybe what
event they have coming up because
they've indicated that before so I think
just the ability to serve as a customer
online is often so much higher touch so
much more focus and personalized and
there's a lot of benefits that can come
with that so for us from an investor's
standpoint yeah we're definitely seeing
the trend you'll with the e-commerce
companies that we meet with I feel like
we're hearing a lot more about having
some sort of strategy around offline yet
showrooming be a pop ups or be it you
know a full physical store like Brent
the runway has so definitely a trend and
a sign that there are still things in
the online channel that just aren't
figured out right so the sensory piece
which jenny was just talking about you
know the ability to touch the field to
sample to really see what the item is
the ability to have you know discovery
throughout a store right so you can walk
around you might go in for one thing and
then all of a sudden you find something
else so you know the online companies I
think we're trying to solve that by
presenting to you some some very curated
and some very different or tailored
things that you would necessarily see
otherwise but that's still something
that's in progress it isn't completely
figured I think the physical experience
still doesn't quite match that the other
thing is you know an education
standpoint you know sometimes with these
larger purchases that are more expensive
the ability to have somebody in the
store who can actually educate
customer and really try to sell them on
the concept and this is not so much on
the fashion side you know maybe
electronics or something like that
there's definitely something there and
again the online guys are trying to
mimic that and do their best to you know
have more content around a purchase to
tell stories around purchases and we're
actually really big believers in the
marriage of content plus commerce as a
real differentiator the other thing is
obviously instant gratification right
you walk away with the item which jenny
just talked about you know so the online
world is doing a lot in terms of fixing
that you know there's obviously been
some acceleration and shipping we've
seen shipping times really decelerate in
terms of you know being two weeks three
weeks and now we're seeing things like
one-day shipping you know I don't know
if anyone's tried out prime now which
now can even deliver within two hours
here in Manhattan or if you're willing
to pay the 87 99 it's within an hour
right they're delivering it to your
trunk of your car now 20 is that I'm
latest thing even if you're not in your
car packages can be placed in your car
right it it's it's pretty crazy so and
delivering to two stores as you were
saying which is another way that they do
that and then finally the last piece
that's still missing and the online
experience is you know that social
aspect right so you're going to the mall
with your friends or you're going to the
store with your friends and that ability
to share the experience together so
again I think the online guys were
making some really interesting strives
with social media with the ability to
share with the ability to talk about
different things but we're not quite
there yet so that's why I think we're
seeing more the online e-commerce
companies going towards a bit of an
offline strategy you know guilt is
experimenting with showrooming and I
think what has been successful in that
strategy that they've done you know
starting the same way that you guys did
is to really have you know a selection
of highly curated personalized items
with a stylus there you know an expert
who can really help them figure out you
know how do you mix the items together
how do you pull an outfit together you
know within an assortment that's already
been highly curated in the first place
so I think there's a there's interesting
opportunity i also just wanted to
quickly touch on the fact that i also
think that's a big conversion from
offline to online right so you know
we've heard a lot about beacon
technology as an example you know we
have in our portfolio company called
swirl that just announced recently that
they're doing some interesting works if
you can imagine going into a store you
know they're actually working with Orton
Taylor and I
me and Fitch you can go into the store
you have prior to that agreed to either
have their app on your phone or you may
have agreed to or they may have a
partnership call it with it with it with
the weather apps so that when you're
walking into that store you will get
some notification about something so
depending on where you are specifically
in the store they know where you are
they know what you're looking at they
can feed you something in terms of a now
that's very specific to you and that's
very powerful also imagine from the
retailer standpoint they can see where
you are in the store right did you hover
too long in this area that you hover to
along in that area there's a lot of
interesting a/b testing that can be done
to really try to get a sense for what
are the consumer preferences you know is
it better to have the red sweaters up
front or the green ones or whatever the
case may be and I think at some point
there will be an interesting full
feedback loop where that information
gathered in store as you mentioned can
then be used to show you some really
interesting and relevant information
online as well but I feel that that
beacon technology is still in the early
days you know the merchants the
retailer's really aren't sure exactly
how to use it yet you know it's really
the early innings of that but it's
certainly an interesting technology that
we're keeping a close eye on I'm going
to actually just add a couple things
because I think this is just such a it's
an exciting thing that's happening right
now and whereas many of you guys have
not rented the runway probably heard of
bonobos and I think what bonobos is
doing with showrooms is also really
enlightening because you can have a
smaller collection of items in store but
the ability to access the full breadth
of their portfolio online and have that
delivered same day next to a to your
home right so you may go you going to
know both you actually don't walk out
with the product from bonobos they call
them guide shops but you try things on
and then they're delivering the exact
color you want your exact size to your
home so I think that that's another
interesting way retail can kind of play
with online and I think the other thing
which I would just give everyone is a
takeaway as I think the retail and
e-commerce play best hand in hand when
you can think of a unique experience and
kind of like a sensory experience that
someone can have in store when they
can't have online and Scarlett touched
on this some so you think about for
example Rent the Runway it's like all
right I'm going to take the time to go
in store how can we make it fun how can
we make it different so one thing we do
is we have you work with a stylus and we
book
actually 45 minutes we're like you have
your personal stylist we pre pull
dresses that are sitting in your
dressing room ready for you based on
what event you have what size you are
what your style preference is so it's
this like celebrity esque experience we
do fun things like if we know we're
coming in for your wedding we'll have
someone there ready like kind of rate
the dresses with little cue cards so i
think when consumers are taking the time
to go into a physical store their arm is
expecting something extra they're
expecting you know whether it's a cool
magic mirror that they can see which
there's technology around that like
changes the color of a dress when you
swipe or you know working hand in hand
with the stylist you need to think about
how can it become this fun different
thing that they couldn't otherwise get
online and I think there is where you
see the most success at brick-and-mortar
currently right so I think we're seeing
a lot of convergence mobile or online
strategies are being applied in the
stores whereas some store strategies are
being applied online I think education
is a big part in for a woman especially
the touch in the field of fabric and how
it fits your body is really important
it's Pilate it's not only you want to
buy what somebody's wearing on TV but
there's an idea that if you know a
celebrity that has a body type similar
to yours you can see them wearing this
product and suddenly it's more appealing
because you know kind of how it fits um
I wish all of us has Liberty tight
bodies but you know we're getting there
um so you guys mentioned a little bit
but data data probably plays a huge role
in the shift from online to offline and
I think data is severely important and
any personalized competitive online
retail strategy so you've mentioned some
ways that data is already being used in
e-commerce but how could it be better
leveraged yes so I think we're you know
I'm sure the beginning of beacon
technology I think we're maybe not at
the beginning of data but certainly
there's a lot more work to be done there
I can talk a little bit to guilt you
know and Jenny talk to us with respect
to her experience as well but knowing
the history of what the customer has
done but the customer has looked at what
the customer has purchased it just gives
you so much data around which to create
a very tailored solution so you know the
landing page that I will have when i
land on gilt will be different than
Jenny's landing page and different than
Ali landing page and what I see next
time will again be different from what I
just saw so there's just a lot of power
and data and you know and I mentioned
the convergence of offline and online
and trying to bring that offline data
onto online trying to figure out how to
how to determine you know which user is
which where the purchase happened so
there's there's still more to be done on
that front but the the the biggest
advantage is really in being able to
really tailor the story to the consumer
specifically and when the consumers
overwhelm with so many choices and so
many websites and so many apps so many
places to do the purchasing to be able
to really create something specific to
him or her is really differentiating
I'll just add one area that we've
struggled with and I'll kind of share
with you what our data driven solution
has been so that's fit and fit is
incredibly important to rent the runway
again people are renting for the most
special events in their lives they
wanted to fit and work out we have like
one chance to make that happen because
the dress gets there the day before
sometimes the day of their event so it's
this important high stakes thing for us
and we actually found that there wasn't
really great big data out there that was
helping with fit or that was at least
letting women feel comfortable and
confident about fit we talked to
thousands of women tens of thousands of
women were like why is this and the
answer we kind of found and we believe
as women ourselves is that it's not just
will this dress fit its will this dress
look good on me so I think there's that
element combined with that but like
every single woman think she has a
unique body type like and she does do
some extent but like she's convinced
that like the typical rules of data
cannot be applied and she actually needs
to see it on herself so what we decided
was the closest thing we could do to get
to that was to create a shopping engine
that was actually driven by photos of
real women so we had women on rent the
runway who are naturally sending in
reviews of the dresses they had worn and
they wanted to share with the community
how great they they felt and they loved
we started asking them all what's your
height your weight your bust size and
women were like fine and great to share
this with that so they started doing
that and then we now enable women
through a concept called our runway to
shop via those photos of real women so
you can input your height your weight
your bust size and you can see tens of
thousands of photos of women like you I
think we have over 300,000 photos now
for example and then you can see you
know what else did this woman rent if
it's someone you identify with or you
think yeah you know she has a similar
body type because there are women out
there who have you know similar body
types and kind of
imagine that outfit on you rather than
on a size double zero model so for us
that has been a big breakthrough in
terms of conversion just letting women
actually feel in the most real way to
them like how a dress might look on them
perfect so Jennifer in my google
stocking of you I came across a quote
that I really liked which is Facebook
killed outfits and that is so true if
you wear a dress now to an event people
take photos it's all over Facebook and
social media and you can't really wear
that dress again we've also seen on a
different note things like if you
Instagram your meal you get a discount
on that the idea is that the marketing
span behind you sharing this meal with
your social network is worth the free
meal or with Khloe and Isabel you have
women paying off their debts with this
e-commerce platform so what role do we
see social media playing and continuing
to play in e-commerce retail in the
future of fashion um so Facebook kills
out that's I'm sure all you guys can
relate to that right men in the audience
the worst thing when you wear dress out
someone post the photo that night and
you can't wear the dress again for me
that statement like summarizes a lot of
why we started Rent the Runway it was
this observation you know in late 2008
that in our world today women were more
obsessed with ever than with their image
they kind of were their own brands
because they were being talked about and
posted on all these social platforms um
they couldn't repeat their outfits
anymore because these photos were being
shared and posted they also had higher
aspirations to look and feel great and
we're amazing outfits because these
photos were being shared with their
whole social communities and beyond they
now also had access to all these photos
of celebrities and learning about like
the brands that celebrities are wearing
and aspiring to new different designer
labels etc etc so those are some of the
consumer trends that when we spoke to
women and we kind of took a step back
and said what's going on in the market
led to our creating rent the runway and
I think you know it just speaks to
there's so much changing in the world of
social media in the world of you know
digital ecommerce that there's new
things you need to do every day as
companies to adapt to consumers and like
we challenged ourselves with that still
you know we view ourselves as a very
disruptive company but we're still like
how can we
take that one to ten steps further
because that world around us is changing
so much further so it's those insights
that I think tell you that the time is
right for a concept like rent the runway
or other disruptive companies and I
would encourage any budding
entrepreneurs to try to like search and
look for like what is different today
versus yesterday what's different now
than a year ago and how is that
impacting consumers from our standpoint
in terms of social media you know we
think it plays a critical role right now
in e-commerce and a little bit of what I
talked about with respect to mobile and
that being a key part of an e-commerce
strategy I think social is now that as
well and you know what I find is you
know this generation is overwhelmed with
choices and would like some influencers
to help them to determine what are the
right choices but doesn't necessarily
want to give the brands or the companies
the ability to be that influencer I feel
that that right needs to be earned for
for some of these companies for them to
become you know the merchandiser of
authority you know with a company like
dill you know that's built over years
and years and years where they are given
the trust and the credibility to be able
to make that assortment in that curation
on behalf of the customers but today I
find that the influence comes more from
peers so you know customers are happy to
share and and and tell each other
stories of what they've worn and and
what they like and products that they
are engaged with and that that's all
great from the standpoint that from a
company standpoint it it really helps
them with customer acquisition it really
helps them with customer engagement and
that's all driven by that that social
media and the consumers in this
generation really not wanting to have
them the company tell the stories but
they want to hear the stories amongst
themselves so I do think social media
has has a really important role to play
in terms of socially influencing some of
the decision-making that goes on today
and like I said no from our standpoint
as we think about e-commerce and the
companies that are successful and some
of the hardest challenges who really are
around building a brand and building
customers and and and reducing that
customer acquisition cost you know being
able to leverage that that social media
channel and and have customers talk
about your product and talk about the
brand and talk about the company or in
the case of chlorine Isabelle tell the
story of what the brand did for them
right so
for those who aren't familiar with that
with that company the the idea is to
really disrupt direct sales and the
company will engage a number of women to
be sellers of their jewelry through
their own customized online stores and
actually they supplement it with an
offline component they have some pop-up
shore so that talks a bit to the to the
concept we were talking about before so
they're the ones they're the brand
ambassadors they're the ones we're out
there telling the story and that's you
know and they're doing that often
through social media channels and that's
a great way for the company to build its
visibility to build its brand and to
then get the end customers who are
actually purchasing the product
absolutely so starlet at softbank you
focus on gamification media digital
media ecommerce just name a few
gamification though is a buzzword and
the business community right now so I
was wondering if you can speak a little
bit about what we're seeing in terms of
retail and gamification or e-commerce
and gamification yes I think we've seen
it for a while now you know guilt was
built on the back of referrals and
membership in this concept of
exclusivity and there you know there
were loyalty programs there there were
things like having early access having
special access those are all
gamification tools and certainly it's
something that we encourage and we see
and and those are successful techniques
to to either engage the customers to get
them to purchase to get them to tell
other people to get more customers so
definitely a believer in gamification as
a way to accelerate the business of
these e-commerce companies you know I'll
give you a quick example guilt last week
did an exclusive partnership with Kim
kardashian-west for her new selfish book
that's actually not launching till next
month and they had this early preview
where there were 500 copies that were
autographed and individually numbered by
her she tweeted and posted about it the
day before I think there was something
like 800 thousand likes and posts or all
sorts of social engagements and when the
books went on sale the next day they
sold out in one minute right so she
built that anticipation there's a
scarcity factor there that is critical
and important really
acting the customers and sure enough you
know it's old instantly and then they
were actually a few other books that
sold the same day as well so you know
definitely feel that gamification is
really interesting technique I think
that the companies that have been the
smartest about doing it and what I like
better is when there's already been some
demonstration of some value that the
company's obtained before they give away
whatever it is so as an example you know
it's not until you've made three
purchases that you then get the right to
you know give something away or give a
referral or a free gift or something
like that so that you've already
recouped upfront some of that
acquisition costs through the prior
customer who already has engaged and
already spent some money yeah so I gave
the example of our runway which I think
with these photo reviews is there's a
form of gamification we've actually
found that often our consumer wants to
share and wants to give data and
information as like sometimes even more
when you don't give them an incentive or
reward so I think there's also been a
trend of like so many almost freebies or
incentive things that customers almost
like are a little skeptical about it and
sometimes just the sheer like desire to
share with the community or hey I looked
and felt great in this dress like makes
them want to share on their own which
has been wonderful for us another what I
guess you could call gamification tool
that we've seen a lot of success with is
called Rent the Runway pro um and allah
amazon prime it enables you for a flat
fee and ours is thirty dollars a year to
get free shipping and insurance on your
orders and then there's other perks like
you get a credit for your birthday and
you get to you know I think gift a
friend address and all of that so that
for us is driven loyalty in a huge way
and so I think just looking at what
other companies have done in the
gamification space i know we looked a
lot at what guilt had done as we thought
about our customer acquisition strategy
is a great a great tool these days and
amazon certainly has so many people
focused on it that i know it's one place
we we look a lot so rent the runway is a
little disruptive and the fact that it
allows access without ownership you can
use this dress and then return it you
don't have to buy it I know guilt and
other sites offer designer labels at a
discounted price flash sales and whatnot
and so we see this trend of almost
democratizing luxury
what does this mean for big brands big
designer labels in the future so rent
the runway when we first started we were
like class what our designers going to
think of this concept I think I'm like
it are they not going to like it and one
of the first things we actually the
first thing we did before we even like
really knew what our company was going
to be called was weak Oh cold called
emailed dan von Furstenberg for what we
thought was her email address and it
turns out it was but she responded right
away and like pink bubble letters I come
to my office tomorrow at 2pm and we're
like it was just actually Diane von
Furstenberg or what's going on but two
girls in business school were like you
know Taipei we're like let's do it let's
go for it and so we walked in there and
for like an hour and a half g told us
why she hated our contact and I you know
for any entrepreneurs they're like this
this happens I you know I think of
entrepreneurship as like a flying a
plane at low altitude there's highs and
the lows feel like you're going to crash
but what came out of you know all of her
bashing of our burgeoning concept then
was the realization that we really
needed to service our customers but also
to service the designers because that
was that was half of our business you
know that's we're spending money on
inventory all the time and so we started
thinking about well what's what are
happening right now in the retail world
so it's November 2008 and you have
retailers slashing prices all these big
brands are looking for ways to kind of
preserve brand value brand equity and
develop brand value so yet you have fast
fashion company zara H&M etc who are
really the only brands and companies
that are growing in substantial ways
during this time so we said you know
here's a way for these designer brands
to get younger women who currently
aren't purchasing their product into
these dresses at moments in their life
that are the most special talked about
moments so that future further down the
road in life they're more inclined to
purchase from those brands so you
imagine a young woman going to her prom
she rents a dress from rent the runway
she gets a ton of compliments that
evening women are always like oh you
look great that's the first thing women
say to each other and they talk about
these brands ten years down the road
when they've saved up and they're
purchasing they're more inclined to stop
at that section of socks or
Bloomingdale's or what have you and they
feel comfortable there they have this
amazing memory with the brand so for us
that's the the value that we offer to
our designer partners we're constantly
talking to them or sharing data
and we're saying listen this is not a
consumer in their 40s and 50s which is
actually the average age of the
consumers of most of the top designer
brands this is a young woman who's going
to look grade is going to go out there
and talk and post on social media and
start to learn and discover your brand
through experiential marketing and be
more inclined to purchase your brand in
the future and we are constantly working
on that feedback loop so that we can
always be delivering on that promise to
our brand partners it's essentially we
haven't talked about that but that's
also very much the guilt the guilt story
you know really being able to put in
front of a very young affluent you know
fashion savvy audience you know these
brands that they wouldn't necessarily
have known about or even come close to
for another five or ten years or
whatever it is so that's a message that
really resonates with the brands and
that I think is why they work so closely
with companies like mint the runway and
guilt you know it's also you know on the
guilt side it's really for them a bit of
a marketing platform as well you know so
there's been some partnerships in the
past you know as an example and I I'm
not a car person I can't matter the name
of the carpet it was the new Infiniti a
couple of years ago q50 or x50 who knows
what it was but there was a partnership
it was guilt it was infinity it was Tom
Brown and Zac Posen to design a really
cool interior specifically to to that
brand marketed to the guilt audience you
know and so that was a really
interesting way for a brand to have
access to this audience and to really be
able to tell the really unique and
special message and to marry that with
some interesting pool up-and-coming
designers that this audience is is in
tune with so you know definitely at that
brand level certainly a message that
works very well with them in terms of
being put in front of this audience I'd
also say that the other thing that is
looking to do is is to show you know the
full assortment so that you'll see some
you know very well known luxury brands
that really interesting prices I really
play to that value and curation side but
there's also the ability to put in front
of this audience you know brands that
they don't necessarily know be at a
brand from Japan or some new design or
out of Korea so that assortment and that
curation is also something that's very
interesting and also to have some of the
more basic items as well so it's really
back to the messages you know you've got
the audience you've got their trust you
know you show them the brands that are
as well known but they may not know but
you also show them brands from other
regions that are up-and-coming and
emerging and they like that you know
that's discovery and that's helping them
to find something that would have been
exposed to otherwise awesome sign over a
little bit low on time but before we let
you go I was wondering if you could
speak just briefly to either the biggest
challenge you face and your role in your
company or any advice that you have for
young entrepreneurs especially woman who
may want to start something of their own
entrepreneur would be you okay I'll try
to address both a little bit and I guess
they're they're kind of related and my
theme overall would be like you can do
it and just go do it so for two and a
half years I ran our warehouse and
launched our vertically integrated dry
cleaner which is now the second largest
dry cleaner in the u.s. I had zero
experience in operations logistics
supply chain dry cleaning for sure I now
know an awful lot about dry cleaning if
there are questions um but you know what
we had to figure it out we were a
startup company our business depended on
it we decided it was a competitive
advantage for us to develop unique
skills in that area no one was really
doing what we were doing in terms of a
hundred percent reverse logistics dry
cleaning all your products etc so like
who better to figure it out than than
you and I think you know just this kind
of especially for women confidence in
yourself put your head down figure it
out get it done I often say like no
doesn't mean no it doesn't it just means
not right now so the Diane von
Furstenberg story is another example of
that it's like okay there's all these
problems constantly being thrown at you
but like put your head down and just go
after it and have some confidence in
yourself that like you know what you can
figure it out and I think so often that
you know that confidence is what's
lacking and women who are starting their
own companies and sometimes it's
reflected and when they're pitching to
investors and you Carly we can maybe
speak to this but first of all you a
fewer women who are pitching to
investors on you often have males at
rooms of male VCS who can be whether
it's intimidating or they just don't
relate to a female-driven concept as
much that's another challenge and then
often women are a little bit more
conservative practical whatever you want
to call it in there pitching approach
and they're talking about a company
that's a hundred million two hundred
million dollar company versus a billion
multi-billion dollar company whereas VC
strategies are off in a line to pick the
one in ten billion a multi-billion
dollar company rather than you know
50-50 chance that a company is going to
be a hundred or two hundred million so I
think that that's kind of worked against
female entrepreneurs in the past I think
there's a really great trend right now
you have more and more early-stage funds
who are actually excited and looking for
a hundred to five hundred million dollar
companies and they are like you know it
doesn't have to be the
billion-dollar-plus idea in fact there
are so few of those that realistically
they exist like let's get behind a
company that we think has a good shot at
being under a million dollar business
and so I think with that as well as a
lot of other examples and support in the
industry you're seeing a huge turn and
the tide of female entrepreneurs and
people are hip to the fact that no one
can better understand a female
consumption pattern than a woman herself
and that women are consuming about
seventy percent of online goods and
products so it's really important we see
examples everyday like gilt groupe like
rent the runway where this is working
this happening and it's making money and
so I think we're at the beginning and
things are just getting better and
better so I completely echo everything
that Jenny says the only a couple things
I would add is I had no idea when I
graduated Yale this is where I'd be
today and there's been lots of paths and
lots of turns along the way so you know
even some of those things that you're
doing that you didn't expand ticipate
doing everything is a learning
experience all that is great you know
I'd say jump in you know as an early
stage investor in a growth stage
investor you know we love hearing the
ideas we love the innovation so keep
those coming and keep trying I think
it's a great time to be an entrepreneur
male or female but you know the access
to capital is incredible the access to
mentorship is incredible the access to
resources you know being able to find
resources to help you build things you
can find all that online now you know
the access to information is incredible
and there are there are a lot of people
that you can turn to source females you
know like Jenny said you know I I'm
lucky to work with three female female
lead companies which is great no I
certainly couldn't have said that five
years ago I'm seeing more and more
people walking in the door you know and
as Jenny pointed out you know the
audience for these products is often
times than women themselves so there's
definitely a connection there in terms
of understanding how the product works
and and understanding the audience so
it's a great it's a great time to be an
entrepreneur and you know I think it's
your forms like these are great to it
really falls for that well thank you
both so much and thank you all for being
such an awesome audience to thank you